carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
que russian de las artes se encuentra en
el festival de cine de cannes reciban un
cordial saludo desde el certamen de cine
más importante y grande del mundo y aquí
estamos para hacerles vivir lo más
importante y destacado de esta gran
fiesta del cine mundial
[Música]
cannes se viste de gala para una
fastuosa celebración del cine de autor
en la competencia 21 películas venidas
de todo el mundo pero sólo una se
llevará la palma de oro el festival de
cannes abrió con la película coupé final
court del francés michel hazanavicius
carrusel de las artes habló con él y con
una de sus protagonistas la
francoargentina bérénice de ello cannes
promete una lluvia de estrellas por la
alfombra roja y homenajes especiales a
forest whitaker mientras que el actor
francés lanzó landon presidirá el jurado
[Música]
estamos en el festival de cine de cannes
certamen que como cada año renueva su
compromiso con el gran cine de autor y
que promete este año reunir durante 12
días a la crema y nata del séptimo arte
mundial como siempre una competencia por
la palma de oro la máxima recompensa de
este certamen son 21 largometrajes
venidos de todo el mundo con grandes
firmas como los hermanos dardenne david
cronenberg o hirokazu kore eda
[Música]
y
los muertos vivientes se apoderaron del
palacio de los festivales en la
proyección de la película coupé final
con el francés michel hazanavicius una
cinta que derramó litros de sangre y
causó muchas carcajadas
para que ocupe la última locura
cinematográfica del prolífico michel
hazanavicius inauguró el certamen de la
riviera francesa la cinta narra la
filmación de una película de zombies de
bajo presupuesto que se ve afectada por
la irrupción de verdaderos muertos
vivientes
cooper está protagonizada por home and
you guys y la francoargentina bérénice
bejo quien nos dio cita en cannes vamos
a verla
[Música]
salomé
no
pero mis bellos muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros en carrusel de las
artes háblanos de esta película final
code o en francés coupé que va a abrir
el festival de cine de cannes donde hay
mucha sangre cómo te sentiste en esta
película además donde hay muchas peleas
muchas decapitaciones muchos cortes de
brazos y de cabeza no me encantó lo
filmamos después la segunda lockdown
entonces estábamos todos ordenamientos y
el confinamiento estaban todos muy
contentos de ir a filmar juntos de poder
hacer una película muy divertida como
chicos no ponerse sangre ponerse heridas
gritar correr esas cosas que casi es
cuando te de disfraces pasada para
halloween y era como un grito de alegría
de fin de colegio o principio de
vacaciones vamos a trabajar todos juntos
así que fue una experiencia realmente
increíble de grupo y la película cuenta
eso cuenta un director que hace una
película perdón pero de [__] con
actores muy malos con técnicos muy
feos también y como ese director va
logrará hacer esa película como juntos
van a lograr a ir hasta el final y
terminar esa película es como un making
of entender qué pasa atrás de la cámara
cómo trabaja la gente cómo se lleva a la
gente es bueno cuando tienes más de 10
personas juntos haciendo algo hay
pruebas de ego de poder de gente que se
enoja de gente que tiene imaginación y
logra encontrar maneras de hacer algo es
una película que habla de todo el mundo
de los técnicos de los actores y
justamente cómo fue para ti porque es
una película dentro de la película y de
hecho tú lo resumimos muy bien es una
película de 30 minutos por pedido de una
japonesa con poquito dinero
mala que se tiene que hacer en una sola
toma y luego nos explican por qué fue
mala exactamente lo que es gracioso que
empiezas la película y te decís pero
esta película es realmente mala los
actores actúan mal y no entiendes por
qué y no entender realmente lo que pasa
bueno hay que esperar un poco se explica
todo
y bueno sin decir todo lo que pasa en la
película base sorpresa sorpresa y bueno
en la primera parte de la película es
media hora de plano secuencias no se
corta nunca y eso lo trabajamos un mes
todos juntos los actores pero también
después los técnicos porque la cámara se
mueve como milímetro y mucho subimos
bajamos salimos entramos cortamos
cabezas gritamos hacemos tantas cosas
que todo está muy bien calculado y todo
el mundo sabe común la coreografía lo
que tiene que hacer y dónde tiene que ir
así que nos tomó un mes de hacerlo pero
fue una experiencia realmente increíble
y ahora esta película final code coupé
abre el festival de cine de cannes están
fuera de la competencia quizás eso sea
un poco menos menos nervios de estar en
la competencia cómo te sientes
regresando al festival que es un
festival que tú conoces muy bien y
michel a servicios también de abril me
parece una idea muy linda me parece que
abrir con una comedia hoy en día donde
realmente estamos viviendo
un momento muy complicado del mundo de
la pandemia la guerra y no creen creo
que estamos todos muy
inquietos cansados no sabemos muy bien
lo que va a pasar y de repente de decir
bueno abrimos el festival con una
comedia que habla de cine que habla de
solidaridad de estar juntos de juntos lo
vamos a lograr hasta el final me parece
que el mensaje que manda ahí es muy
lindo y bueno es verdad que así como
parece más de 10 años que vengo seguido
acá y no estar en competición es nada
más placer es más una excitación de
sentarme en la en la sala y de escuchar
dos mil 500 personas riéndose es va a
ser va a ser increíble nosotros te
deseamos un lindo festival y muchísimas
gracias berenices muchas gracias luego
nos escuchen y para el director de esta
cinta michel hazanavicius era importante
volver a traer la risa a través del cine
y el hecho de haber filmado esta
película luego de la pandemia y de
reírnos como niños con escenas o chistes
tontos ligeros nos permitió liberar toda
esta tensión nos hizo mucho bien a todos
y quizás la gente tiene sed de comedia
estoy muy feliz de traer un poco de
felicidad estamos viviendo momentos muy
difíciles pero no podemos dejar de reír
[Música]
el festival de cine de cannes comenzó
entre vestidos de gala y poses para los
fotógrafos sobre la alfombra roja pero
la gran sorpresa de la noche inaugural
fue la intervención del presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski para
denunciar la invasión rusa a su país
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el festival de cannes eligió este año al
actor francés band son landon como
presidente del jurado una apuesta a
alguien que ha sido fiel a este certamen
y que se ha destacado en películas con
temáticas sociales que hablan de la
brutalidad en el mundo laboral
avanza un landon ocupa un lugar
particular en el séptimo arte francés en
la pantalla grande le gusta encarnar al
hombre contemporáneo a la vez frágil y
enojado con el sistema y la sociedad
bajo la dirección de este fan que se
interpretó una trilogía de corte social
desde el desempleado humillado en la luz
la ley del mercado rol que le valió el
premio de interpretación masculina en
cannes pasando por el sindicalista
explosivo de la guerra silenciosa o el
alto ejecutivo en un nuevo mundo más
real spears y forest artista cualquier
persona con suave sazón y bebe esta
calle está cutis
seguro
y actor prodigioso de una sensibilidad a
flor de piel y selecto con los roles que
interpreta se le ha visto a sí mismo
como el marido infiel de manual de lyon
bom o el protector de un inmigrante
kurdo en welcome también ha prestado su
físico para personajes históricos como
el libertino casanova o el escultor
jodan
[Música]
en 2021 la cual set los recibió con la
ultra violenta titanio cinta de horror
que se llevó el galardón a la mejor
película
[Música]
al elegir avanza un landon como
presidente del jurado que entregara la
palma de oro en 2022 el festival de
cannes ha apostado por un amigo fiel que
ha desfilado en nueve ocasiones por la
alfombra roja de este certamen desde
van son landon estará acompañado en
cannes de otras ocho personalidades que
conforman el jurado cuatro hombres y
cuatro mujeres escribiendo amor es más
habilite es una responsabilidad enorme y
la única forma de lograrlo es volver a
ser ese espectador que uno era de niño
no me gusta la idea de juzgar películas
quiero más bien recibirlas estoy que
explotó de felicidad yo si tú siempre
uno subió luego de jodie foster en 2021
el festival de cannes entregó su palma
de oro de honor al actor estadounidense
forest whitaker celebrando así por todo
lo alto su carrera como intérprete
productor y director de cine nos lo
cuenta felisa barra
[Aplausos]
forest whitaker recibió su primer
galardón en cannes en 1988 por su
magistral interpretación de charlie
parker en el biopic verde de clint
eastwood
[Música]
once años después whitacre volvió a la
alfombra roja del festival junto al
cineasta jim jarmush por su película
ghost dog en la que interpretó a un
samurai urbano de los tiempos modernos
[Música]
y
su actuación en el último rey de escocia
de kevin macdonald lo coronó en 2006 con
el premio al mejor actor en 26
certámenes incluidos los oscar los bafta
y los globos de oro un reconocimiento a
su feroz interpretación del dictador idi
amín dadá apodado el carnicero de uganda
un papel que sin duda marcó su
compromiso social fundó en 2012 una ong
dedicada a promover la educación para
sacar a los jóvenes de la violencia en
uganda así como en otros países de
áfrica méxico eeuu e incluso francia
también ha sido nombrado enviado
especial para la paz de la unesco
[Música]
alguno
oriundo de texas whitacre ha actuado en
más de 50 películas y series colaborando
con cineastas como martin scorsese y
oliver stone pero además se ha destacado
como director y en la última década como
productor
[Música]
terminamos este carrusel de las artes
anunciándoles una de las
superproducciones que veremos este año
en cannes elvis la esperada biografía
del rey del rock and roll protagonizada
por austin butler y tom hanks así que
como rock and roll terminamos este
carrusel y les damos cinta para la
próxima semana aquí en cannes agua
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]